this movie picks up right where we left
the moment the momentum that you are
leaving and we just saw it and I thought
how did you it's been how many years
it's more than I thought it was like six
five yeah that's been six six years how
is that beard yes Wow that beard yeah
thank you yeah yeah I can't take all the
credit
no no no the beard won two Emmys but
what else caught what blew me away was
just you had to get right back into that
incredibly intense headspace of Jesse in
that moment which you left six years ago
how do you do that truthfully this this
this scene that you just saw that that
screaming actually took like almost half
of a day which is wild to think about
but that was the hardest day on the
entire shoot just happened to die of me
screaming crying laughing all of the
above you know it was pretty it was
pretty rough but I I know this guy so
well you know I lived and breathed every
moment of his life you know that
happened to be on screen and then some
but when I first read the script I just
I felt like I just knew all these
emotional beats right right so I so you
get back into it and then a lot of us
have noticed that it's called El Camino
a Breaking Bad movie not V a Breaking
Bad movie which of course to people like
me and there are a lot of us gets us
thinking realize that you know they'll
be more yeah you know what it used to be
the Breaking Bad movie or they had a
version of it
the final chapter right and now it's a
breaking but it now gets me guessing
like is it yeah is that it what I love
it's probably gonna be like a year from
now there'll be a Breaking Bad Christmas
they broke you know they go around the
Christmas tree making math you know hey
special guest star it's Michael Buble
hey you know what's great is that
obviously and for many years when you
were doing breaking bed you would come
on this show and we would comment on
your your your catchphrase which one
yeah don't make me do it
but yeah [ __ ]
you realize you're set for life because
thirty years from now if you've got
nothing else going on they can always
say Erin pot will be at the Minnesota
Civic Center and he's going to stayin on
he's gonna say yeah [ __ ] once
tickets are $155 packet you come out
there's a warm-up you know and then you
come out yeah yeah [ __ ] wings response
but you know what's great is that it
wasn't you read the script for El Camino
and it wasn't in there was not in there
yeah so you decided to take matters into
your own hands
I did yeah I I gave my first improvised
yeah [ __ ] I never like improv a [ __ ]
in the history of Breaking Bad every
single [ __ ] you saw on screen was
scripted it was a scripted [ __ ] yeah
and but I run I've read I read al Camino
and I didn't notice the first time
around but I think maybe third or fourth
time I read I was like wait there's no
there's no [ __ ] in here yeah you know
so I called Vince like it's is there a
reason there's no [ __ ] in here he's
like oh I didn't even think about it and
then that was it but then when we were
shooting there was a love of telling
well it I don't know spoilers but where
you put it is so great this is not
really spoiling if you haven't seen it
Jesse's making a salad and he's standing
inside like a salad line and it's a
beautiful salad and he looks at it and
it was just a spur-of-the-moment thing
when I placed the tomato on top of the
salad it just came out like I said I
know this guy's so well it just came out
I didn't mean for it to happen and I
just said yeah [ __ ] about the perfect
Saturday perfect salad I mean
it was a perfect placement of it yeah it
was really good it's great you think of
it yeah